This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down,
这是一个I-Heart播客。百分之百真人。在Look Back at it播客中。从1979年开始，这对我和我来说都是一个重要时刻。84年对我很重要。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利士。每集我们挑选一个年份，剖析发生了什么，
and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the Outer. My Heart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
并试着理解我们是怎么熬过那段日期的。我们的朋友、喜剧演员同行以及最喜欢的作家。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔谈80年代。84年是疯狂的一年。那是疯狂的一年。我认为没有哪一年对黑人更重要了。在Outer收听look back at it。我的Heart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方。
Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host, Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast.
嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？欢迎收听Learn the Hardway，我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·加姆斯。这个空间关乎黑人群体的经历，进行坦诚的对话，这些对话在任何地方都不安全，但你正在与一位知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士进行对话。多少男人穿着盔甲。它向世界表明你不是好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这样做，在AHA电台应用程序、Apple Podcast或您获取播客的任何地方收听learn the hard way。
In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice in so much, correct? I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian, Michael Mancini. My mind was blown.
2023年，“单身汉”明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控生下一对双胞胎。但这次怀孕似乎是个骗局。你两次篡改了这个特定的测试，对吗？我篡改了一次测试。需要一大批网络侦探才能揭开一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。格雷格、一个女同性恋者、迈克尔·曼奇尼。我的大脑震惊了。
I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello, everybody. welcome back to the show. Welcome back to another episode. This week, it's a fabulous, wonderful guest episode with a lovely human. I'm so glad to have her on board. Thank you. Oh my gosh. That's so sweet.
我是斯蒂芬妮·扬。这是“爱之陷阱”。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察。随着季度的继续，劳拉·欧文斯最终面临后果。在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听“爱之陷阱”播客。你好，欢迎回到你的二十多岁心理学，这是一个我们探讨二十多岁的一些重大生活变化和转变及其对我们心理学意味着什么的播客。大家好。欢迎回到节目。欢迎回到另一集。本周，这是一个极好、精彩的嘉宾节目，有一位可爱的人。我很高兴她能加入。谢谢。哦，天哪。太甜了。
What's your name? Yeah. I'm glad you want me to introduce myself now. Yeah. I'm Laura. Hi. Hi. Hi. Yeah. It's so fun to be here. Yeah. It's really exciting. Laura, how do we know each other before we jump into? We have a mutual friend. Yeah, EJ. Yeah, because she's on the podcast. EJ and Gia. Yeah, they were literally on my. Yeah, they were last time.
你叫什么名字？是的。我很高兴你现在想让我自我介绍。是的。我是劳拉。嗨。嗨。嗨。是的。很高兴来到这里。是的。这真的很令人兴奋。劳拉，在我们深入了解之前，我们是怎么认识的？我们有一个共同的朋友。是的，EJ。是的，因为她上了播客。EJ和贾。是的，他们实际上在我的。是的，他们上一次在。
Yeah, well, EJ and Gia are my roommates. Yes. So we went out to dinner and then we got chatting and here I am. That's how it works. If you ever want to come on the podcast, I'm just going to like vaguely approach you after that could be a Mexican dinner and be like, hi. You should come on the podcast. That's basically what I did with you.
对，嗯，EJ和贾是我的室友。是的。所以我们出去吃晚饭，然后我们开始聊天，我就在这里了。事情就是这样运作的。如果你想上播客，我会在那之后含糊地接近你，那可能是一顿墨西哥晚餐，然后说，嗨。你应该上播客。这基本上就是我对你做的事。
Remember I stood into your Instagram deals? Well, because, yeah, you said it like at dinner when I told you about what I was doing at uni. And then I was like, oh, I think she, I think I might be on the podcast. And I was just kind of waiting to see if it actually, if it actually happened. Yeah. And then you messaged me. And I was like, so exciting. I've been chosen. Yeah. I always stick to my word. I feel like once I've like met someone, I'm like, I love this. I love your vibe. Yeah. And I go, it sounds like I'm like approaching you for like a three. So I love your vibe. That's really funny. But like I love their vibe. They have an interesting story of which you do, which we're going to get into very short.
还记得我看了你的Instagram reels吗？嗯，因为，是的，你在晚饭时说过，当我告诉你我在大学里做什么的时候。然后我就想，哦，我想她，我想我可能会上播客。我只是在等它是否真的发生。是的。然后你给我发了信息。我就想，太激动了。我被选中了。是的。我总是信守承诺。我觉得一旦我见过某个人，我就想，我喜欢这个。我喜欢你的氛围。是的。然后我说，听起来我好像在接近你进行三方约会。所以我喜欢你的氛围。这真的很有趣。但是，我喜欢他们的氛围。他们有一个有趣的故事，而你也有，我们马上就要深入探讨了。
I'm like, here we go. Yeah. Next step. So maybe that's worth talking about. Yeah, what I do. But why are you on the show today? What's special about you? I was special about me.
我就像，开始吧。是的。下一步。所以也许这值得谈谈。是的，我做什么。但你今天为什么来这个节目？你有什么特别的？我有什么特别的？
Well, the thing that made you approach me was my uni degree. So I do a degree in forensic mortuary. So I don't know if for people who don't really know what that means, when someone dies, I will perform an autopsy and figure out how they died, essentially. Yeah. Yeah. So I do a medical degree. Yeah.
嗯，让你接近我的原因是我获得了大学学位。所以我获得了法医尸检学位。所以我不知道对于那些不太明白这意味着什么的人来说，当有人去世时，我会进行尸检并找出他们的死因，本质上是这样的。是的。是的。所以我获得了医学学位。是的。
A medical degree. Yeah. I think that's a really great way to put it. Yeah, because it's Bachelor of Medical Science, in brackets, forensic mortuary. That's my official title. That's great. Okay. One thing that I wanted to know is how many people are in your course.
医学学位。是的。我认为这是一个很好的表达方式。是的，因为它是医学科学学士学位，括号里是法医尸检。这是我的正式头衔。太棒了。好的。我想知道的一件事是你的课程里有多少人。
Because, so I'll just quickly say this. The reason also I wanted to bring you on was because I'm trialling this new series called unconventional, where I get people such as yourself who, are doing career paths that I wouldn't say an alternative, like it is still a definite established career path and something that is very necessary in society. Yes. But something that I think most children aren't like, when I grow up, I want to be a mortician. Yeah.
因为，所以我会很快说这个。我邀请你来的另一个原因是因为我正在试用一个名为“非常规”的新系列，我邀请像你这样的人，他们正在从事我不会说是替代路线的职业道路，就像它仍然是一条明确确定的职业道路，而且是社会非常需要的道路。是的。但我觉得大多数孩子不会说，当我长大了，我想成为一名殡仪馆工作人员。是的。
The same way that they're like, I want to be a ballerina or I want to be a doctor or what. Yeah, exactly. So I was like, this is such an interesting, an interesting concept to me. And you're such an interesting person that you have decided to do this. Yeah. So how many other people would you say are in the same boat with you? Well, I'm pretty sure there's 18 of us currently because I'm in my last semester at uni. So in two weeks, that's it.
就像他们说，我想成为一名芭蕾舞演员或我想成为一名医生或什么。是的，完全正确。所以我想，对我来说这是一个非常有趣的概念。你是一个如此有趣的人，你决定这样做。是的。那么你觉得还有多少人和你处境相同呢？嗯，我很确定目前有18个人，因为我在大学的最后一个学期。所以在两周内，就是这样。
I'm graduated. Yay. Yeah, very exciting. Very nerve-wracking, but exciting. But yeah, I think there's 18 of us currently. But I don't think that everyone actually will go into the field of forensic mortuary technician. I think that a few people want to go on to do research and things like that. Yeah.
我毕业了。耶。是的，非常令人兴奋。非常伤脑筋，但令人兴奋。但是，是的，我认为目前我们有18个人。但我不认为每个人都会真正进入法医尸检技术员这个领域。我认为有些人想继续做研究之类的事情。是的。
So it's very small compared to my other uni classes because I have like a placement like unit and yeah, there's 18 of us. 18 people. Yeah. And what do you mean by research? Because you obviously want to be hands on. Yes. I think a lot of people just want to do it maybe as like a stepping stone into other kind
所以与我的其他大学课程相比，它非常小，因为我有一个实习单元，是的，我们有18个人。18个人。是的。你说的研究是什么意思？因为你显然想亲力亲为。是的。我想很多人只是想把它作为进入其他类型的一种垫脚石。
of medical things. I'm not really sure. We have a lot of people from very diverse like areas. I know, like, someone I used to do it with, wanted to be a teacher, was a teacher beforehand and has now transitioned. So there's a lot of different stories within how people end up there, because it's definitely not. It's unconventional.
医疗方面的事情。我不太确定。我们有很多来自截然不同领域的人。我知道，比如，我以前一起做过的人，想成为一名老师，之前是一名老师，现在已经转型了。所以人们是如何到达那里的有很多不同的故事，因为它绝对不是。非常规的。
Yeah, exactly. I was going to say normal, but I was like, no, unconventional. That's a very good word. I think it's totally normal. Do you think, what do you think of some of the common, sorry, we're about to get into serious questions? Yeah, of course. I'm just kind of like spitballing here.
是的，完全正确。我本来想说正常，但我想，不，非常规。这是一个很好的词。我认为这很正常。你觉得，你觉得一些常见的，对不起，我们要开始问严肃的问题了吗？是的，当然。我只是在这里随口说说。
Yeah. This is so fascinating. But what do you think is some of the reasons people get into this. field or why did you decide like this is what I want to do with my life right now? Yeah. Well, um, I've always been really into like science and I've really loved like biology, that kind of thing, um, at school. And I think I used to, I always really, I've always really, but yeah, boys really. I used to want to be a vet because I really like animals, obviously. You know, that that's what I do is my side hustle at the moment.
这太迷人了。但你认为人们进入这个领域的某些原因是什么，或者为什么你决定这就是我现在想用我的生活做的事情？是的。嗯，我一直对科学很感兴趣，在学校里我真的很喜欢生物学之类的东西。我想我曾经，我一直真的很，但我一直真的很。我曾经想成为一名兽医，因为我显然很喜欢动物。你知道，我现在把这当作我的副业。
Yeah. He was looking after dogs. Exactly. That's carrying me through uni. But I really, I ended up doing a volunteering work at a vet clinic when I was probably about 14. And I really liked, like, watching the surgeries. I thought it was really interesting. The reason that I stopped doing that was because when people were crying about putting
是的。他一直在照顾狗。没错。这支撑我读完大学。但最终，当我大约14岁时，我在一家兽医诊所做志愿者工作。我真的很喜欢看外科手术。我觉得这很有趣。我停止这样做的原因是因为当人们为把他们的狗安乐死而哭泣时，我也只想和他们一起哭。这太让人心碎了。我就想，如果我和每一个人都哭，那就太不专业了。所以我换了职业，然后当我16岁时，我真的很迷恋BBC的一部名为《无声的证人》的剧。我以前每周五都和我妈妈一起看。是的。讲的是什么？它是关于法医病理学家的。
their dogs down, I just wanted to cry with them. And it was so heartbreaking. And I was like, this is not very professional if I cry with every single person. So I switched and then when I was 16, I was really obsessed with this show called Silent Witness on the BBC. I used to watch it every Friday with my mum. Yeah. What's it about? It's about a forensic pathologist.
哦，好吧。那就这样吧。所以，法医尸检技术员就是我之后要做的工作。是的。而法医病理学家有点像更高级别，我之前做过的护士与外科医生的类比。是的。所以它是关于外科医生的，法医病理学家。
Oh, okay. There we go. So yeah. So forensic mortuary technician is what I will be after this. Yeah. Whereas forensic pathologist is kind of like the higher, the analogy that I made to earlier about the nurse versus the surgeon. Yeah. So it was about the surgeon one, the forensic pathologist.
是的，我只是觉得看她解剖人非常有意思。是的。而且因为我对医学一直很感兴趣，我开始在谷歌上搜索如何成为一名法医病理学家，然后我发现了这个学位。从16岁开始，我就一直坚持下来了。我只是决定，好吧，这就是我要做的。是的，所以我真的没有，我想我只是偶然遇到了它，然后我一直坚持下来。
and yeah, I just thought it was really interesting, watching her dissect people, essentially. Yeah. And because I've always been interested in medicine, I just started Googling how to become a forensic pathologist, and then I found this degree. And then since I was 16, I just kind of stuck with it. I just decided, okay, that's what I'm going to do. Yeah, so I don't really, I just kind of stumbled into it, I guess, and I've just stuck with it.
但是，当我刚刚完成我的学业时，因为我在最后一个学期，我刚刚完成了临床实习期，我真正喜欢的部分是觉得当他们无法照顾自己时，我在照顾他们。哦，这是一个绝佳的表达方式。是的，因为有几个案例相当具有对抗性，或者因为我们工作的一部分是寻找死因。所以你需要了解他们的病史。他们的个人历史，我们从警方那里得到了关于发生的事情的故事，诸如此类的事情，以便我们，病理学家知道要寻找什么。
But I've really, whilst, because I've just finished. my, because I'm in my last degree, in my last semester, I've just finished my clinical placement period. And the part that I actually found that I've really enjoyed about it was feeling like I was taking care of people when they couldn't anymore. Oh, that's such a beautiful way of putting it. Yeah, because there was a couple cases that were quite confronting and or because obviously our job is to find cause of death. So you need to know their medical history. their personal history, we get a story that comes kind of with them from the police about what happened, that kind of thing so that we, and the pathologist knows what to look for.
因为重点是尽可能做到微创，因为如果不需要，你真的不想对某人进行所有这些手术。如果你只需要做一次扫描，CT扫描就可以找到死因。但其中一些更具挑战性的，感觉真好，在我们完成一个程序后，特别是有时我们洗他们的头发。我们清洗尸体，你知道，我们确保他们真的很干净，并恢复他们。哦，工作的一部分是恢复。是的。所以，洗他们的头发，梳理他们的头发，确保他们得到照顾，感觉真好。即使这是一件很难做到的事情，它也让我觉得我在
Because the whole point is to be as non-invasive as possible, because you don't really want to be, you know, doing all these procedures to someone if you don't have to. If you could just do a scan, a CT scan and find a cause of death. But so some of the ones that were more challenging, it felt really nice to like, after we'd done a procedure, especially sometimes we wash their hair. We wash the body down, you know, we make sure they're really clean and we restore them. Like, part of the job is restoration. Yeah. So it's, it felt really nice to be able to wash their hair, brush their hair and make sure they were, like, taken care of. And it felt, even though it was a hard thing to do, it made me feel like I was
在某种程度上帮助了他们，而他们却无能为力。是的。是的。所以我觉得这实际上是我在去实习之前没有想过的事情，但这真的让我感觉很好。就像，我觉得我在做一件非常有价值的事情。是的。是的。这绝对是惊人的。我，就像，这是这样的，并不是说有什么错误的答案。是的。
helping them in a way when they couldn't help themselves anymore. Yeah. Yeah. So I think that's actually something that I didn't think about before I went on placement, but that really, it made me feel good. Like, it felt like I was doing something so, like, so worthwhile. Yeah. Yeah. That is absolutely stunning. I, like, that is such, not that there are any wrong answers. Yeah.
多么美好的回答。你觉得这是一种普遍的动机吗，比如想要，很明显，你来到这里时是这样的，我只是对此着迷。我有一个虚构的英雄，他做这种工作，它把我带入了这种领域。但是你觉得现在你开始在这个行业中以职业水平工作了吗？就像快要毕业了，它将成为你的工作。
What a beautiful answer. And do you think that that is, like, a common motivation, like, wanting to, obviously, you came into this being, like, I'm just fascinated by this. I've had this, you know, fictional hero who does this kind of work, and it's brought me in. into this kind of field. And but do you think now that you're kind of beginning to work in this profession on a professional level? Like doing it as almost, you're almost about to graduate and it's going to become your job.
是的。如果你正在考虑从事这种工作，你认为真正重要的技能或品质是什么？是的。所以每个人，几乎我在实习期间互动的每个人，他们都有，我们都有同样的尊重。很明显，你知道，这不是一件正常的事情，这项工作。每天和死人打交道是不正常的。
Yeah. What do you think some of those really important skills or traits are to have if you want to, if you're considering pursuing this kind of job? Yeah. So everyone, pretty much everyone that I like interacted with whilst I was on this placement period, they all, we all had that same respect. Like, obviously, you know, it's not a normal thing, this job. Like, it's not normal to deal with dead people every day.
这非常具有对抗性，而且精神上很累人。但我从来没有在工作环境中感到如此多的支持，就像我在实习期间一样。因为我记得我的讲座之前确实和我们讨论过这一点，就像我今年开始的时候一样，与你的同行和未来的同事建立联系是多么重要，因为除了这些人，没有人会理解你正在经历什么。所以它就像这个美丽的社区，每个人都分享这种尊重，就像我们正在做的事情有多么重要，你知道这个人，无论他们是谁，都有人爱他们。他们是某人的整个世界，找到发生了什么来给那个家庭一个交代是如此重要。但是所有这些
And it's very, like, confronting and mentally tiring. But I've never felt more supported in a work environment than when I was on that placement period. Because that I remember my lectures have actually discussed this with us before, like, when I started kind of this year, that it's so important to make those connections with, your like your peers and your co-workers in the future because no one else will understand what you're going through than those people. And so it was like this beautiful community and everyone shares this respect for like how important what we're doing is and that you know this person like whoever they are someone loved them. They were someone's entire world and it's so important that we find out what happened to them to give that family closure. But to all that
作为一个人的尊重他们，确保他们得到照顾，我从每个人身上都感受到了这一点，这是一种共同的信仰和动力。是的。我想这回答了你的问题。确实如此。老实说，这真的改变了我的看法，因为我认为当我们想到处理尸体的人时，这可能会非常奇怪。是的。你发现这是很多人的反应吗？是的。我，当我告诉别人我做什么时，我得到的唯一两种反应，这经常发生。我觉得我一直在谈论我的学位，因为你知道你去理发店，他们问你在忙什么？
respect them as a person and to make sure that they're taken care of and I felt that with everyone that that's a shared kind of belief and like the motivation for it. Yeah. I think that answered your question. It really did. Honestly, it's really changing my perspective because I think when we think of people who deal with dead bodies, it can be really strange. Yeah. Would you find that's like a reaction a lot of people have? Yeah. I've I, the only kind of two reactions I get when people ask what I do, which comes up all the time. I feel like I talk about my degree all the time because you know you go to the hairdress and they ask you what you're up to?
我说，哦，我在上大学。他们说，哦，你在大学里做什么？然后我不得不说，我不能对付死人。是的。天哪。是的。我只是，哦，我在互联网上做事情。是的。
And I go, oh, I'm at uni. And they go, oh, what's you do at uni? And then I have to go, I can't up dead people. Yeah. And what, oh, my God. Yeah. I just like, oh, I do stuff on the internet. Yeah.
是的，我要么得到，哦，天哪，哇，太酷了。我喜欢NCIS。就像有多少人说，哦，我以前喜欢犯罪心理。或者我有几个人有点说，哦，他们给了我这种奇怪的表情。就像，哦，好吧，这使得。甚至有人曾经告诉我，哦，这让我觉得有点不舒服。我说，好吧。
Yeah, I either get like, oh, my God, wow, that's so cool. I love N-C-I-S. Like the amount of people that are like, oh, I used to love criminal. minds. Or I've had a couple people who kind of go, oh, and they give me like this weird look. Like, oh, okay, that makes. And someone even told me once that, oh, that makes me feel a little uncomfortable. And I was like, okay.
为什么？总得有人这么做。是的，完全正确。而且我认为老实说，我实际上正在和我在实习时的一位主管谈论这件事，我觉得很大程度上是因为你，你知道，就像你看电影和电视节目那样。很多时候，殡仪馆的人和那些人，他们被画成这种有点像变态的人。我正要说，显然我遇到了你。
Why? Someone has to do it. Yeah, exactly. And I think that honestly, I was actually talking about this with one of my supervisor I had on placement that this, I feel like a lot of it is because you, you know, like you watch movies and TV shows and that. And a lot of the time, like, the morticians and that, they're painted as like these kind of like creeps. I was going to say that that's, obviously, I met you.
我真的很喜欢你。是的。我们相处得很好。你是个可爱的人。我希望你们能看到她在麦克风外是多么可爱。谢谢。但我认为我的观点正是如此。就像在我遇到你之前，这些人就像奇怪的中年男子，不知何故都在我脑海里出生。
I really like you. Yeah. You get along very well. You're a lovely human. I wish you guys could see how lovely she is off the microphone. Thank you. But I think what my perspective is like exactly that. Like before I met you as like, these people are like strange, like middle aged men who are all born for some reason in my mind.
我总觉得这将是一个奇怪的比较。但是如果你见过的话，你看过河谷镇吗？不，我没有。我没有。你知道吗？我很高兴我没有。因为现在我总是在TikTok上看到它，我就想，这太糟糕了。但我喜欢，它在我15岁的高中时上映。
I always think of this is going to be such a weird comparison. but if you've ever seen, did you watch Riverdale? No, I didn't. I did it. And you know what? I'm glad I did it. Because now I like see it on TikTok all the time and I'm like, it's so bad. But I like, it came out in high school when I was like 15.
所以我成了目标人群。有一个，天哪，人们会认为我很奇怪。但上面有一个家伙是殡仪馆工作人员，他被称为Cuddle博士什么的。他是最令人毛骨悚然的家伙。他们把他描绘成一个绝对的变态。他总是像，他就像拿走。
So I was the target demographic. And there's, oh my God, people are going to think I'm so weird. But there's this guy on it who's the mortician and he's like called Dr. Cuddle or something. And he's the creepiest dude. They paint him as like this absolute creep. And he's always just like, he's like taken. bribes and stuff and just being all like they always film him like he's just like eerie and it and I hate
贿赂之类的东西，只是表现得像他们总是拍摄他，就像他只是诡异一样，我讨厌它，因为人们看了那个然后像，是的，你认为这就是随之而来的耻辱的一部分吗？我想是的。就像，那些与死人一起工作的人，比如殡仪馆工作人员之类的，人们总是把他们看作，为什么，因为这很奇怪。是的，因为他们就像，好吧，你有什么毛病？你为什么要和死人一起工作？是的。但是，好吧。
it because then people watch that and then like yeah do you think that's some of the stigma that comes along with I think so I'd like yeah like people who work with dead people like people like funeral directors or something like that people always see them as like what that because it's weird yeah it's because they're like well what's wrong with you why do you want to work with dead people yeah yeah but Yeah. Here we are. Yeah. But I do think that that definitely is something.
我们来了。是的。但我确实认为这绝对是一回事。我越深入其中，我就越想，哦，我希望这不是一回事。因为它是。就像那里的每个人只想照顾好这些人。就像你说的，总得有人做这份工作。是的。就我个人而言，我觉得这非常有趣，因为我喜欢它的科学性。我对人体的解剖学有着如此的热情，因为我认为我们喜欢的方式太有趣了。
The more that I get into it, the more I'm like, oh, I wish that that wasn't a thing. Because it is. Like everyone there just wants to take care of the people. And like you said, like someone has to do this job. Yeah. And I like personally, I find it very interesting because I like the science of it. Like I have such a passion for like anatomy. of the human body because I think it's so interesting the way that we like,
就像出生然后继续生活，还有我们的身体一直让我们保持活着的方式，比如你的器官系统等等。我只是觉得这太有趣了。是的。这就是我喜欢它的地方。但这也是能够照顾这些人的额外部分。是的。你知道，这就是我对它的看法。
like born and then keep living and just the way that our bodies keep us alive all the time, like your organ systems and that. I just think it's so interesting. Yeah. And that's what I love about it. But then it's also the added bit of like being able to take care of those people. Yeah. You know, that's kind of my thing about it.
是的。你会说这是你工作中最好的一部分吗？是的。是的。我想是的。是的。而且我认为也是因为，就像，我只实习了两周，但我觉得每个人都非常友好和亲密，因为这是一段只有极少数人能理解的经历。是的。
Yeah. And you would say that's like the best part of your job? Yeah. Yeah. I would think so. Yeah. And I think as well because, like, I was only on placement for two weeks, but I felt like everyone was so friendly and close to each other because it is an experience that only a very few amount of people are going to understand. Yeah.
因为特别是这个领域也很小。而且，你知道，这不是大多数人能感同身受的事情。所以感觉就像一个真正的社区，不错的环境。这也真的很棒。是的。是的。因为我可以想象，请纠正我如果我错了，职业倦怠的程度会相当高。是的。我认为我们确实做到了，这个学位的辍学率也相当高，我想。只是因为显然有些人不喜欢，这不适合他们。这种工作绝对不适合所有人。
Because especially the field is really small as well. And, you know, it's not something that most people can relate to. So it felt it was like a real kind of community, nice environment. And that was really nice as well. Yeah. Yeah. Because I can imagine, and please correct me if I'm wrong, like the levels of burnout would be pretty high. Yeah. I think we do get, there is a quite high dropout rate in this degree as well, I think. Just because obviously some people don't, it's not for them. It's definitely not for everyone, this kind of job.
但是，是的，肯定有，显然有些人以极其创伤的方式死去。或者即使它们不是创伤性的，如果它反映了你生活中发生的事情，它也会。相当触发。所以，是的，在那个领域工作的人肯定会有时候吓坏了，无法应付。但就像我认为这就是为什么那个社区如此重要。重要。是的。这引出了我的第二个问题。第二个问题。下一个问题。我觉得我已经问过你了。我们已经触及了很多事情。我知道。我已经问了你很多问题了。但你认为最难的部分是什么？除了你知道的耻辱感，就像你说的，被你自己的经历所触发，这是不可避免的，
But yeah, there's definitely, obviously some people die in incredibly traumatic ways. Or even if they're not traumatic, if it mirrors something that's happened in your life, it can. be quite like triggering. So yeah, there is definitely times where people who work in that field are going to freak out and not be able to cope with it. But like I think that's why that community is so important. Important. Yeah. And that kind of leads to my like second question. Second question. Next question. I feel like we've already asked you. We've touched on many things. I know. I've already asked you so many questions. But what do you think is the hardest part of this? Other than you know, the stigma, like you said, being triggered by your own experiences, which is unavoidable,
我想，在许多行业中。但真正的是，你认为最难的部分是什么？听起来，我不认为对我和心理上的打击是最难的部分。我认为我的是物理性质，这是一项体力消耗很大的工作，你一整天都要站着。我认为这是，我知道这是一个相当无聊的答案。不，不，这非常有趣。但这，是的，这只是体力消耗很大。
I think, in many professions. But what is really, what do you think is the hardest part? It sounds, I don't think that for me, the mental toll is the hardest part. I think mine is like the physical nature is that it's quite, it's a very physically intensive job and you're on your feet all day. I think that's, I know that's quite a boring answer. No, no, that's very interesting. But it's, yeah, it's just quite physically intensive.
事实上，我前几天还在想，除了污名化之外，这是一份艰苦的工作。显然，既有情感上的，也有体力上的。劳动强度非常大。你一直都在站着，你知道，人们很重。你必须抬起东西，你知道。哦，有趣。就像，因为，你知道，移动尸体之类的东西。就像，它们很重。
And that's actually, I was thinking about this the other day that along with the stigma thing, it's like it is a hard job. Obviously, both emotionally but also physically as well. It's very like labor intensive. You're on your feet all the time, you know, people are heavy. You have to lift things, you know. Oh, interesting. Like, because, you know, moving bodies around that kind of thing. Like it's, they're heavy.
所以人们，你知道，在情感上和身体上都很艰难。所以如果人们不喜欢，我想在这里说什么？如果人们对它不是那么热情，他们就不会做。这不仅仅是一份因为简单而陷入的工作。你需要有激情去想做那份工作。你需要关心每天去上班。是的。
Yeah. And so people, you know, it's hard both emotionally and physically. And so if people didn't like, what am I trying to say here? That if people weren't so passionate about it, they wouldn't do it. It's not just a job that you fall into because it's easy. It's you need to be passionate to want to do that job. You need to care about going to work every day. Yeah.
你知道，这很重要。你知道我的意思吗？是的，绝对的。我觉得很多工作都是这样。但特别是在你的行业中，我认为我们大多数人不喜欢思考死亡，这是一种非常非常人性化的动物反应。甚至在我们录制这一集之前，我们就在长篇大论地讨论失落、悲伤和死亡，以及这有多困难。你是否认为在某种程度上，与那些不再活着的人密切工作已经影响了你，当谈到，
That, you know, that's the important. You know what I mean? Yeah, absolutely. And I feel like that is the same with a lot of jobs. But particularly in your profession, I think most of us don't like to think about death, which is a very, very human animal reaction. Like even before we were recording this episode, we were having this massive chat about loss and grief and death and how difficult that is. And do you think that in any way that working so close to those who are no longer alive has impacted you when it comes to,
你生活中发生的其他事情？我认为，是的，它绝对有，就像我之前对你说的，当我们谈论我们的失落和一切时，是的，我，我个人在生活中失去了几个人。这实际上，它激励我在这个学位上更加努力。因为我认为，特别是在新冠疫情期间，你知道，大学里的每个人，我认为都在努力应对一切都在网上的事情。是的。但我真的很挣扎着去寻找动力去做这件事，
other things that have happened in your life? I think that, yeah, it definitely, like I was telling you before this when we were talking about our loss and everything, that, yeah, I have, I've personally lost a few people in my life. And it actually, it kind of motivated me to push harder in this degree. Because I think, especially during COVID, you know, everyone at uni with, I think we're struggling with everything being online. Yeah. But I really was kind of struggling to feel motivated to do it.
但我认为有我个人的经历，它让我更想帮助这些人的家属，因为我经历过那一面。是的。你知道，当你失去某人时，这是多么创伤。所以，特别是出乎意料的时候。所以我认为这促使我更想去做，这意味着现在我可以参与找出他们的亲人发生了什么，并能够告诉他们，发生了什么。
but I think having those my personal experiences, it made me want to help the families of these people more because I've been on the side of that. Yeah. You know, I know how traumatic it is when you lose someone. So, like especially unexpectedly. So I think that kind of fueled me to want to do it more because that means that now I can be a part of finding out what happened
而且，我不知道，我觉得整天和死人在一起。我觉得它实际上在某种程度上让我变得更有同情心，更有意识。因为很明显，你知道，我是，你周围都是死亡或白天，它让你真的，它只是让我真的很感激。是的。就像活着一样，是的。
to their loved one and being able to tell them, like, what actually happened. And, yeah, I don't know. I think it kind of the being around the dead people all the time. I think it actually in a way has made me like more compassionate and more like just more aware. Because obviously, you know, I am like you're around death or day and it makes you really it kind of just made me really appreciate. Yeah. Like being alive and yeah.
对人也更温和一点，因为我不知道，你知道，他们失去了谁。甚至像现在有时我看到的那样，因为我看到了这么多不同的人走过，有时我在街上看到人们，我就想，哦，哇，他们让我想起了这个人，就像它让我想要变得更好，因为当我们得到这些人，我们看到他们的生活故事，是的，它只是让我觉得我不知道其他人身上发生了什么，因为那是某人过着的悲伤的生活，现在我得到了照顾他们，但是当我在外面和活着的人在一起时，它让我感到了更多的同情心，因为我真的不知道他们可能会经历什么。是的。感觉就像给了，
And just being more gentler on people as well because I have no idea, you know, who they've lost. or even like sometimes now I see because I've seen so many different people come through that I sometimes see people in the street and I'm like oh wow like they remind me of this person and like it makes me want to be nicer because when we like get these people and we see like their life story yeah and it just makes me be like I have no idea what's going on with anyone else because that's this sad life that someone has lived and now I get to take care of them but like when I'm out around living people, it just makes me feel so much more compassion because I really have no idea what they could be going through kind of thing. Yeah. It feels like it's given,
就像你能够以解决问题的形式给别人一份礼物。是的，完全正确。老实说，这就像最好的事情之一。是的。如果你失去了意想不到的人，你可以希望。完全正确。或者在非常悲惨的情况下。是的。只是得到了这种闭幕的礼物。但它也给了你，更强大的同理心礼物，是的，我会说你已经是一个非常富有同情心的人，所以谢谢你只是被放大了，但它是，我只想触及那部分，只是你对我说的一件事，我当时想，哇，这真的很有趣，当你看到街上的人时，是的，他们看起来像你在他们最脆弱的时候看到的人，是的，生命的终点状态，这很奇怪吗，还是更多的是，或者它只是一种单一的反应，就像因为我，因为你可以理解它，因为你让我想起了一个我想更好地对待你的人，还是它可以像是一种情绪化的反应，是的，有时我认为它绝对可以，特别是如果有人看起来很相似，很明显，我在实习了两周，所以我感觉当你在那里工作时，显然你会发生更多的事情，但有时阅读人们的故事，是的，你可能会对某人感觉更多，因为你看着他们的故事，你就像，哦，哇，这和我相似，我认为如果你在公共场合看到看起来像他们的人，那么这将是一件更多情绪化的事情。但我也认为，很多时候就像你对那种事情变得麻木一样，因为你有点必须这样做，如果你走进门，每天都对死亡感到如此悲伤，你将无法胜任这份工作。是的。最终，我是，你知道，我在那里是为了尽我所能做好这项工作，并确保这些人得到照顾。所以我想，你需要离开它。把那个留在家里。而且，是的，有一个，你真的必须在精神上相当坚强，能够将你的工作与你的家庭生活分开，不要把工作带回家。但是，是的，我绝对就像有时我，是的，你会看到人们，我就长得像这个人，或者，
like you're able to give a gift to others in terms of closure. Yeah, exactly. Which is honestly, like one of the best things. Yeah. You can hope for if you've lost someone unexpectedly. Exactly. Or in really tragic circumstances. Yeah. It's just being given that gift of closure. But it's also given you, a much stronger gift of empathy yeah and i would say you're already an incredibly compassionate person so thank you just have been heightened but is it um i just want to touch on that part that just one thing that you said to me that i was like wow that's really interesting when you see people on the street yeah who look like people that you've seen at their like most vulnerable yeah end of life state um is it is it strange like or is it more or is it just that singular
你认为哪些案件是最难的？你觉得是和我们一样年轻的人吗？是的，我不知道，是的，很明显，是的。儿童总是很难。但我发现更多的故事，是的，当你读到一个没有人陪伴或孤独的故事时，这是更难的。就像，这比，是的，它非常取决于这个案件。但确实有，是的，儿童是一个难题。有时我甚至发现只是老年人，因为显然我们生活在一个老龄化的社会中。但是，是的，这是，有，是的，它让你意识到有很多老人，特别是像独自死去，我觉得这很悲伤。是的。是的。
reaction of like because I because you I can relate to it because you remind me of someone I want to treat you better or can it be like kind of an emotional reaction yeah sometimes I think it definitely can be especially if someone looks quite similar um and obviously I was on the on placement for two weeks so I feel like when you work there obviously you're more going to happen but sometimes reading people's stories yeah like you might feel more connected with someone because you look at their story and you're like oh wow like that's similar to me and I think then if you saw someone who looked like them in public, then that would be more of an emotional thing. But I also think that a lot of it is like you get quite desensitized to that because you kind of
是的。是的。老实说，因为我，这是一个题外话，但有时我想，哦，我想，你知道，永远一个人，永远不要结婚。单身，过着美好的生活，没有孩子的生活，我只想旅行。然后我想，另一面是，如果我最终死了，没有人找到我呢？
have to because if you go in and you're like so sad about death every day, you're not going to be able to do the job. Yeah. And like ultimately like I'm, you know, I'm there to do this job as best I can and make sure that these people are looked after. So I kind of, you kind of need to leave that. Leave that at home. And yeah, and yeah, there's a, you really have to be quite mentally strong to be able to separate your work from your home life and not take work home with you. But yeah, I definitely like sometimes I, yeah, you would see people and I'm like, wow,
几周。是的。这些总是因为你读过这样的故事，比如邻居打电话是因为，你知道，窗户上有苍蝇或者有气味，那是。是的，这太痛苦了。这很悲伤。是的。
you look just like this person or, yeah. What cases do you think are the hardest? Do you think it's people who are our age, who are young? Yeah, I don't, yeah, obviously, yeah. children is always a hard one. But I find more the stories, yeah, are the harder ones when you read one that someone had no family or something or that they were alone. Like that is a hard one more than like, yeah, like it's very like determined on like the
哦，这就像，另一个，我今天读了一个非常悲伤的故事，关于这个在西澳大利亚被发现的家伙。有点相关，但不是真的。嗯，西澳大利亚对那些美国听众来说是澳大利亚的一个州，他是，嗯，叫什么来着，不是摩托车手，山地自行车手。哦，山地自行车，是的。他失踪了10天左右，没有人知道他是谁，没有人注意到他失踪了，他在骑山地自行车时发生了非常严重的事故，有个女人带着她的狗找到了他，是的，我当时想，这真的很悲伤，没有人注意到你的缺席。
case. Yeah. But there's, yeah, it's definitely, yeah, children is a hard one. I even find sometimes just elderly people, because obviously we live in an aging, like, aging population. But, yeah, it is, it is, there's, yeah, it makes you realize there's a lot of old people that, especially like die alone, which is very, I find that sad. Yeah. Yeah.
确切地说，是的。就像，没有人注意到你的缺席，因为你的存在，是的，完全正确。没有被感受到。我确信他的存在以我们可能甚至不知道的方式感受到了。是的。但我绝对可以说为什么这会非常非常困难。是的。是的，绝对的。我在两周的实习期间读过一些书。而且感觉就像，因为你往往会聊很多关于它们的事情，因为就像我说的，那个社区，没有人会理解你正在经历什么。所以我们往往，有很多关于，哦，好吧，这很悲伤的讨论。我们都读了这个故事，我们，就像，这真的很棒。
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. I, honestly, because I, this is kind of a tangent, but sometimes I'm like, oh, I want to, like, you know, be alone forever and, like, just never marry. and be single and just like live a great life, a childless life, like, I just get a travel. And then I'm like, the flip side of that is like, what if I end up dead and no one finds me?
是的，有很多关于它的对话。是的，我记得有一个我们在，这太悲伤了，因为，是的，没有家人，就像，他们被抛弃了一段时间。然后那是，是的，这很难，因为，那是，很悲伤，没有人还没有意识到你失踪了或者没有人照看你。是的。是的。你觉得，我觉得这几乎会使你刚才所说的好一点，通过这种方式，你可以给他们那个。完全正确。是的。
Yeah. Weeks. Yeah. Those are always, because you read about stories like that where like neighbors call because of, you know, there's flies on the windows or there's a smell and that's. Yeah, which is so. Which is sad. Yeah.
天哪，你能听到声音吗？那是别人的车吗？是的。抱歉，如果你们能听到，但我们有，有人在录音后面的街上开小派对，出发吧，我们在谈论死亡，他们正在生活。天哪，我绝对很好。人的二元性。
Oh, it's like, the other one, I read this really sad story today about this guy who was found in W.A. Kind of related, not really, but. um w a for those american listeners is a state in australia um and they he was um what's it called not a motor bike rider mountain bike rider oh mountain bike yeah and he had been missing for like 10 days or something and no one knew who he no one had noticed that he was missing and he got into like a really bad accident while he was mountain bike riding and some woman with her dog like found him yeah and i was like that is really really sad that there is no one to know
人的二元性。好的，我们有一点分心，因为有人在街上走来走去，玩得很开心。但我猜这实际上与我接下来要谈论的内容息息相关。我们之前已经谈到过这一点，但你认为这项工作如何改变了你对死亡的看法以及什么是好的死亡？是的。很明显，我认为很多人会认为可能没有好的死法，因为很明显这是一个，这不是一件好事。但我认为这只是让我更加感激活着。
notice your absence. Exactly, yeah. Like, no one to notice your absence because your presence Yeah, exactly. Wasn't that felt? And I'm sure his presence was felt in ways that we might not even know. Yeah. But I can definitely say why that would be very, very difficult. Yeah. Yeah, definitely. There's been ones whilst I was on the two-week placement that we would read. And it's like, because you tend to chat about them a lot as well because like I said, like that community, no one else understands what you're going through. So we tend to, there's a lot of talk about like, oh, well, that's sad. And we all read the story and we, like, that's really nice.
我想我之前说过，但是，是的，我不知道。这很难，就像，说什么是好的死法，因为，就像，你永远不能真正，这是一件你无法真正控制的事情。我的意思是，事实上，我想有些人可以，就，是的，通过自杀之类的。但是，是的，我认为从来没有一个好的死法。但我喜欢我们之前谈论的不要孤单，就像我不会，那不是我不会喜欢被留下，是的，如果这是有道理的。但话又说回来，这就是为什么我觉得这份工作真的很重要，那就是我们可以帮忙，是的，你知道，你发现这份工作让你更多地思考死亡吗？嗯，我确实认为实际上，是的，因为我认为无论那个人是如何死去的，无论是，你知道，一个事故还是一件医疗的事情，我之前对你说过，我从来没有觉得我想在我的生活中更健康。
Yeah, there's a lot of conversation about it. And yeah, I remember there was one where we were, that's so sad because, yeah, no one, no family, like, they'd been left for a while. And then that's, it is, it's hard because it's, it's, that's sad that there was no one yet to realize that you were missing or no one checking up on you. Yeah. Yeah. And do you feel like, I feel like that would almost make what you were saying better, whereby you're able to give them that like. Exactly. Yeah.
是的，关于这个有很多讨论。是的，我记得有一次我们在，这太令人难过了，因为，是的，没有人，没有家属，他们被留在那有一段时间了。然后这就，确实，这很难，因为，这，没人意识到你失踪了或者没有人来看望你，这真的很让人难过。是的。是的。你是否觉得，我觉得这几乎能说明你刚才说的话，即你能够给予他们那种关怀。完全正确。是的。
Oh my God, can you hear the noise? Is that someone's car? Yeah. Sorry if you guys can hear that, but we've got, someone's having a little party in the street behind when we're recording, go off, and we're talking about death, they're living life. Oh my God, I'm absolutely good. Duality of man.
天哪，你听到声音了吗？那是谁的车吗？是的。如果大家能听到这个声音的话我很抱歉，我们在录音的时候，街后面有人在开小型派对，他们在狂欢，而我们在谈论死亡，他们却在享受生活。天哪，我真是太好了。人类的两面性。
Duality of man. Okay, so we had a little bit of a distraction because there were people walking up and down the street, having an amazing time. But I guess that actually really links to what I want to talk about next. And we have kind of touched on this before, but how do you think this work has changed your perceptions around death and what a good death is? Yeah. I obviously, I think that a lot of people would think that there's probably no good way to die because obviously it's a, it's not a good thing. But I think it has just made me appreciate being like alive more.
人类的两面性。好的，我们刚才有点分心，因为有人在街上走来走去，玩得很开心。但我想这实际上与我接下来想谈的内容紧密相关。我们之前也稍微触及过这个话题，但你认为这项工作如何改变了你对死亡以及什么是“好死”的看法？是的。很明显，我认为很多人会觉得可能没有所谓的“好死”，因为这显然不是一件好事。但我认为这只是让我更懂得珍惜活着的感觉。
I think I said that before, but, yeah, I don't know. It's hard to, like, say what a good death is because, like, you can never really, it's one thing that you can't really control. I mean, actually, I guess some people can, in terms of, yes, like, with suicides and that. But, yeah, I don't think there's really a good time ever to die. but I like what we were talking about before of not being alone like I would just not that's what I wouldn't like I wouldn't enjoy being left yeah if that makes sense but then again that's why I think I feel like this job is really important is that then we can help yeah you know do you find that this job makes you think more about death um I I do think actually yeah because I think then in terms of however that person has died, whether it be, you know, an accident or a medical thing, I was saying to you before, I've never felt like I wanted to be healthier in my life.
我想我之前说过，但是，是的，我不知道。很难去说什么是“好死”，因为，你永远无法真正控制它，这是你真正无法掌控的一件事。我的意思是，实际上，我想有些人可以，比如通过自杀之类的方式。但是，是的，我觉得永远没有一个真正适合死亡的好时机。但我喜欢我们之前谈论的那样，不孤单一人，我就是不希望那样，如果被遗弃的话我不会喜欢的，是的，如果这样说得通的话。但话又说回来，这就是为什么我觉得这份工作真的很重要，因为我们可以提供帮助，你知道的。你觉得这份工作会让你更多地思考死亡吗？嗯，我确实这么觉得，因为我觉得不管那个人是怎么死的，不管是事故还是医疗原因，我之前对你说过，我从来没有像现在这样渴望变得更健康。
Yes. Because obviously, you know, obesity and that is a big problem within modern, like the modern world. And wow, I've never wanted. Yeah, well, because even if someone looks relatively healthy on the outside. Sometimes, I don't know if you've ever heard of the phrase, like, I think someone said it when I was in high school, but like skinny fat where it's like skinny on the outside but fat
对。因为显然，你知道的，肥胖症在现代社会中是个很大的问题，就像现代世界一样。天哪，我从来没想过。对，因为即使一个人表面上看起来比较健康。有时候，我不知道你有没有听过这样一个词，好像我在高中时有人说过，就是“瘦胖”（skinny fat），也就是外表看起来很瘦，但内部
on the inside. What does that mean? So like when you have like, not sometimes a poor diet, but like your organs can develop, this is just like a medical lesson. Yeah, give it to us. They develop, you develop more fat around
却很胖。这是什么意思？就是有时候你的饮食习惯不太好，但你的器官可能会长出——这其实就相当于是上一堂医学课。太好了，给我们讲讲吧。它们会发育，你的器官周围会
your organs. So even if you look relatively healthy, in quotations. Yeah. On the outside, your organs can be quite unhealthy. Yeah. And yeah. And so sometimes now I think I'm like, wow, they, when someone I know is quite thin
长出更多脂肪。所以即使你看起来比较健康——加上引号。是的。从外表上看，你的器官其实可能相当不健康。是的。而且，有时候现在我觉得，当我知道的某个人很瘦，
or like you see someone who's quite thin, but maybe they don't eat well, I'm like, they could still be. Really unhealthy. Yeah, really unhealthy on the inside. And it's, yeah, because I don't think about that with myself a lot. Like I think that I, you know, I eat relatively healthy. And, you know, I like, I do my exercise. Yeah.
或者你看到某个很瘦的人，但他们可能饮食不太规律，我就会觉得，他们体内其实依然很不健康。是的，体内非常不健康。而且，是的，因为我平时不太会这样审视自己。我觉得我，你知道的，我的饮食算比较健康。而且，你知道的，我也会锻炼。对。
I'm like, wow, maybe my organs don't look great. That's so weird because you would see them. You would see what it looks like. Well, and that's the other thing as well with, like, I was talking about this with the other people I went on placement with, that now sometimes I see people, and I'm like, I bet I know what your organs look like. Really?
我就想，天哪，也许我的器官看起来并不太好。这太奇怪了，因为你可以亲眼看到它们。你可以看到它们长什么样。不过，这也是另一回事，就像我之前跟我一起去实习的其他人聊过的那样，现在有时候我看到一些人，就会想：我敢打赌我知道你的器官长什么样。真的吗？
Yeah. My God, don't look too close to me. Hopefully my organs are, I'm not. I'm sure your organs would be beautiful. Thank you so much. Don't you worry. I exercise, I promise. I had some strawberries for lunch.
天哪，别离我太近。希望我的器官……我不是……我确信你的器官一定非常完美。非常感谢。别担心。我发誓我有锻炼。我午餐吃了草莓呢。
Yeah. What's the weirdest organ do you think, like, that you, when you're doing your examinations, is there one that you're like, oh, yeah, I can't wait to get to the brain or like, oh, dang, I've got to remove the pancreas or, like, look at the pancreas. I don't think there's one that I, like, oh, they get excited. I do like to look at people's hearts because your heart, I think heart health tells you a lot about overall health, because obviously it's a very important organ. So I do think it's really interesting to see people's hearts,
你觉得最奇怪的器官是什么？比如，当你在进行解剖检查时，有没有哪个器官会让你觉得：“哦，天哪，我迫不及待想看看大脑了”，或者“哦，该死，我得把胰腺切除”或者“看看这个胰腺”？我觉得没有什么器官会让我觉得特别兴奋。不过我确实挺喜欢看人类的心脏，因为我认为心脏健康能反映出整体的健康状况，因为显而易见，这是一个非常重要的器官。所以我觉得观察人们的心脏真的很有趣，
Because even some people who are quite small, your heart weight is supposed to be, like, roughly, I can't remember the percentage, but it's supposed to be a specific percentage of your overall body weight to be healthy. And some people's hearts are just absolutely massive. And you wouldn't even think that. Do they get to control that? Is it about health? Yeah, heart health is about, like, sometimes diet, but mostly exercise because your heart is a muscle. so the more that you work that muscle, then the bigger it.
因为即使对一些体型很小的人来说，你的心脏重量理应大约是——我记不清具体百分比了，但它应该是你总体重的一个特定比例才算健康。而有些人的心脏却大得离谱。你根本不会想到这一点。他们能控制这个吗？这跟健康有关吗？对，心脏健康往往取决于饮食，但主要还是靠锻炼，因为心脏是一块肌肉。你对这块肌肉的锻炼越多，它就会变得越大。
Oh, the bigger it gets. Yeah. Because I think it's, I'm not the best at it, but, well, like, I know that your diet can affect, like, your heart and that kind of thing. I haven't done my medical degree yet. I'm not, I'm not a doctor yet. Yeah, yes.
哦，它会变得更大。对。因为我觉得，虽然我在这方面不是做得最好，但我知道饮食确实会影响心脏以及诸如此类的事情。我还没完成医学学位呢。我还不是个医生。对，是的。
But you know more than most of us, though. But yeah, so, like, it's kind of crazy seeing some people who on the outside, you wouldn't think their organs are that unhealthy, but then you open them up. And oh, my God, wow, look how big that organ is, or look how big their liver is, look how big their heart is. Yeah. So I do enjoy the heart to see that because that's quite indicative.
但你比我们大多数人懂的都多呀。不过话说回来，看到有些人表面上看起来器官没那么不健康，但当你切开他们的时候，却发现：“天哪，哇，那个器官怎么那么大，或者他们的肝脏怎么那么大，心脏怎么那么大。”这种感觉真的很疯狂。所以我也确实挺喜欢观察心脏的，因为这很有指示意义。
But I do always just as well when you first see the organs, it's always very interesting because sometimes it's not what you're expected to see at all. It's just like, whoa, they looked quite healthy. This is not what I expected. So that's quite interesting. But obviously the grossest part is the bowels because... Oh, my God. Yuck.
不过每次刚看到那些器官时，总是觉得非常有趣，因为有时它们完全不符合你的预期。只会觉得：“哇，他们看起来挺健康的，怎么完全不是我想象的那样。”所以这相当有意思。但显然，最恶心的地方还是肠道，因为……天哪。真让人作呕。
Wait, explain. Is that... TMI, but can you explain that more? Like, I thought maybe this is my, like, pleb knowledge. When people die, like, all their, like, unprocessed food just gets exerted. Yeah, no. Sometimes people do, like, I guess, like, pee themselves, poop themselves when they die because of that release of muscles.
等等，解释一下。那是……泄露太多隐私（TMI）了，但你能多解释一点吗？比如，我还以为——也许这是我这种门外汉的认知——当人死后，他们体内所有没消化完的食物都会被排泄出来。对，也不完全是。有时候人们在死后确实会，我猜，比如会尿裤子、拉裤子，因为那是肌肉放松导致的。
But a lot of the times you still get it quite, like, because obviously your intestines is quite a long pathway. Yeah. So if it's, like, somewhere in there that's not close to the end, we just have to like scoop it out well yeah it depends you try to kind of keep the bowel intact because it doesn't smell very nice um because it's a bowel but sometimes it bursts or it'll come out and yeah you just kind of you wear a hell of a lot of PPE like yeah yeah personal protective equipment there's i wear like seven layers whilst your oh my gosh i didn't even think about that
但很多时候你仍然会遇到这种情况，因为显然肠道是很长的一段管道。所以如果它位于肠道中间的某处，离末端还很远，我们就必须把它挖出来。好吧，这得看具体情况。你得尽量保持肠道完整，因为气味真的很不好闻，毕竟那是肠道嘛。但有时它会破裂，或者内容物会流出来，所以，你得穿上超多的个人防护装备，像这样……是的，个人防护装备。我得穿大约七层衣服，而你……哦天哪，我甚至都没想过这个。
pairs of gloves, like, you're really kidded up. Yeah. Because it's, and that's just to protect us, because if, you know, we get everyone from all walks of life, they could have anything. Like, I don't want, I want to protect myself. Yeah. If they have a disease or just like, you just don't really want to get someone else's fluid on you, because that's just not pleasant.
戴好几层手套，整个人武装得严严实实的。对。因为这主要是为了保护我们自己，因为你知道的，我们接收的遗体来自社会各个阶层，他们可能携带任何病菌。我可不想……我得保护好自己。对，如果他们患有什么传染病，或者你就是不想沾上别人的体液，因为那真的很不舒服。
Um, yeah. So you just kind of, you just deal with it. You, it's very much like, if anyone's a nurse, they would totally get it. nurses get very desensitized to poop. Because that's just part of the job and it's same with this. You just, you get used to it. That's crazy because that's a whole different world
嗯，对。所以你只能去面对它。这非常像是——如果谁当过护士，他们绝对能懂。护士对排泄物都变得非常麻木了。因为那只是工作的一部分，这里也一样。你慢慢就习惯了。这太疯狂了，因为这和我从事的工作完全是两个世界。
to the kind of work I do. If someone was pooping on my table all the time, I'd be like, what the fuck? Why is my office friend shitting everywhere? Okay, this kind of off topic but I just want to ask really quick is what's like the biggest,
如果有人一直拉在我工作的桌子上，我肯定会想：这他妈是怎么回事？为什么我的办公室朋友到处拉屎？好吧，这有点偏离主题了，但我只想顺便快速问一下，你的工作里最大的……
if you told someone about your job, like what do you think is a fact of or something that would surprise someone the most about your job? I think the one that I think shocks people is the amount of people that we get in every day, the amount of admissions we have every day. Because obviously everyone knows that people die all the time. But even me when I first started my first day of placement, I was like, whoa, that's a lot of people.
如果你跟别人讲起你的工作，你觉得关于你的工作，最让人意想不到的事实或细节是什么？我觉得最让人震惊的，是我们每天接收遗体的数量，也就是我们每天的收治量。因为显然大家都知道人随时都在死。但就连我刚开始实习的第一天时，也在想：“哇，这人数也太多了吧。”
Yeah. Because you get like, I mean, there's not a set number obviously because it's not an exact sign. but yeah, like it's a lot. And you just don't really think about how many people are dying all the time. And so I think that's, I remember telling my mom about it. And she would ask like, oh, how many people do you have in today? And I'd be like, oh, like nine. And she was like, whoa, nine overnight.
对。因为你会接收到，我的意思是，并没有一个固定数字，因为这并不是一门精确的科学。但总之，数量确实非常多。你平时真的不会去想，到底有多少人每时每刻都在死去。所以我想，我记得我跟我妈提起过这件事。她会问：“哦，你们今天接收了多少遗体？”然后我会说：“哦，大概有九具吧。”接着她就会说：“哇，一夜之间就有九具？”
I was like, yeah. Nine people. Yeah. And how, what's the average for, would you have like an average on a weekly basis? But you obviously don't serve the entire city. No, no, yeah. So there's, because there's three facilities. Does everyone who dies have to go through?
我说：“对，九个人。”是的。那么，平均下来，每周的平均接收量大概是多少？不过你们显然不负责整个城市的遗体接收吧？不，不，是的。所以有，因为有三个设施。所有死者都必须经过……
No. There's a set of legislation that's the Coroner's Act of 2009. I'm pretty sure it is. My God, she's done. She knows her shit. She's going to pass her last exams. If my lecturer is listening to this and I got that wrong, please don't yell at me.
不用。有一套相关的法律法规，叫做《2009年验尸官法案》。我很确定是这个。天哪，她太厉害了。她对这些门清。她期末考试肯定能过。如果我的讲师正在听这个播客而且我记错了的话，请千万别冲我发火。
I'm pretty sure it was Coroner's Act 2009. But yeah, there's a list of, like, reasons why someone would be admitted. So, because normally someone dies and then, Um, if it was, essentially if it was not in, if, if it wasn't expected for that person, if they weren't supposed to die or if they were going in for a routine operation and then died, that they shouldn't, that shouldn't have been the outcome. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. If they're in hospital or if they're in a government facility of any kind, like hospitals, if they're in custody, if they're in mental institutions, like anything like that.
我很确定那是《2009年验尸官法案》。不过是的，有一系列关于为什么某人会被送来验尸的法定原因。通常情况下，如果有人去世了，然后，嗯，如果这是意外情况，如果那个人本不该死，或者他们只是去做个常规手术却不幸离世了——本不该是这样的结果。对，对，对。如果他们是在医院里，或者在任何类型的政府机构里，比如医院、羁押场所、精神病院，诸如此类的地方。
If they're under the care of any government agency, then they get sent to us, even if they're in, they're in custody. they know what happened. Yeah. Interesting. Yeah. Because I thought you were about to say the opposite. And I was like, I'm sorry. If someone died in custody, I feel like I would want an examination of what happened there.
如果他们受任何政府机构的监管，那他们就会被送到我们这里，哪怕他们当时正被羁押。他们得弄清楚发生了什么。对，很有意思。对。因为我还以为你要说相反的情况呢。当时我想的是：如果有人在羁押期间死亡，我觉得我肯定会想对那里发生的事情进行调查。
No, no. Yeah. Yeah. They all get sent. Yeah. And it's, so it's only really like if, because normally someone dies, they'll call up, the police will call up their doctor. Oh, I didn't know that.
不，不。对，对。他们全都会被送来。所以，通常只有当——因为平常有人去世时，警察会打电话给他们的医生。哦，我不知道这个。
And be like, will you sign off on this death certificate? You know, do you think they, do you think that they, this was what you expected for them. And a lot of the time, doctors will just say, yeah, if they've had, you know, if they've had terminal cancer for four years or something, they're going to be like, yeah, I'll sign off on that, that was expected. Or if they're 95, and they've got this host of health problems. Yeah, okay, I'll sign off on that. But I'm pretty sure that doctors can also, part of the Coroner's act is if you don't report, because they're called like reportable deaths. It's what the legislation is under. And if you don't report that as a doctor, you can get.
然后警察会问：“你愿意在这张死亡证明上签字吗？你觉得，你觉得他们……这符合你的预期吗？”很多时候，医生会直接说：“行吧，如果他们已经患了四年晚期癌症之类的，医生就会觉得：‘行吧，我签，这在预料之中。’”或者如果死者已经95岁了，身上还带着一堆健康问题。好吧，行吧，我签。但我很确信医生也必须遵守——验尸官法案的一部分规定是，如果你不报告……因为这些被称为“需报告的死亡”（reportable deaths），法律就是这么规定的。作为医生如果你不进行报告，你可能会惹上相当大的麻烦。所以很多时候，我们接收到的遗体对应的病历都长得惊人，他们在医院住了两年之类的那种，你就会想：“他们为什么会被送到这里来？”因为这只会给家属的悲痛历程增添更多的流程。其实那具遗体本可以直接送去殡仪馆的。他们本可以举行葬礼的。但对。
in quite significant trouble. So a lot of time we do get bodies in where you'll look at the history and they've got this massive long health history and they've been in hospital for two years or something and you're like, why are they here? Because that just progresses in the progress for the family. Like that body could have just been sent straight to the funeral home. They could have their funeral. Yeah. But yeah. It was a bit unnecessary. Like unnecessary grief and trauma. But they tend to err on the side of caution just because they don't want to lose their medical license. But yeah. Yeah. So yeah, there's definitely some that you get in that don't need to be there, but not
这就显得有点多余了。就像是不必要的悲伤和创伤一样。但他们往往会偏向于谨慎行事，只是因为不想丢掉医疗执照。不过是的，对。所以，确实有些被送来的遗体其实根本没必要来，但并不是
every single person who dies will be sent to us. Okay, that is really surprising. There we go. We're learning more. And we've talked about how it's changed your perspectives on death. But something you said to me that really stuck with me when we were chatting before we started recording
每一个去世的人都会被送到我们这里。好吧，这真的很让人意外。你看，我们又学到了新东西。我们之前聊过这如何改变了你对死亡的看法。但你在我们开始录音前聊天时说过的一句话，让我印象非常深刻，
was like, you could die tomorrow. Yeah. So how does it impact on how you live your life now? Obviously you want to be healthier. Yeah. You're a lot more present to every moment and being like, oh wow, life is really amazing. Yeah. But is there anything else that it's really impacted on it for you?
那就是：“你可能明天就会死。”那么，这会对你现在的生活方式产生什么影响呢？显然你会想要更健康一点。对。你会更加专注于每一个当下，觉得“哇，生命真的很奇妙”。对。但除此之外，还有什么别的东西被它深深影响了吗？
I think it's, yeah, it's a hard question because I think I've already, already as a person with my own, like, experiences, I've been very much, like, not taking life for granted. Like, I'm very much, like, a live in the moment kind of person. But, yeah, I do think it, yeah, I really, I just think that it, it just makes me appreciate life more. I'm not sure if there's really anything else. that it's affected in me as a person besides like the compassion like just more that kind of thing. Yeah, yeah.
我觉得，这是一个很难回答的问题，因为作为一个有着自身经历的人，我本身就不是那种会把生活视为理所当然的人。我基本上就是那种活在当下的人。不过，是的，我觉得它确实让我更加感激生命了。我不确定它是否还在我作为个人的其他方面留下了什么影响，除了同理心，就是更多这种层面的东西吧。对，对。
But maybe that's something you'll see as you get more into it. Yeah, exactly. Yeah, like I've only had this very limited kind of experience. Because obviously like I've done, I've done a three year, you need to agree. So I've like known what it was about, but obviously actually experiencing that every day for two weeks is a lot. Yeah, a lot more. Yeah. But yeah, I don't, I don't, it's hard to think of anything.
但也许随着你经历的深入，你会看到更多的改变。对，没错。对，就像我目前也只有这种非常有限的经历。因为显而易见，我读的是三年的学位，所以我在理论上知道这是怎么回事，但实际连续两周每天都去经历这些，感触还是非常巨大的。对，深刻得多。对。不过，是的，我很难立刻想出其他别的什么。
off top of head. I think I might just, it might be something that comes more with time. And is it a job that you see yourself doing for the rest of your life? We talked about this before. Yeah. Let's examine that a bit more. I, it is incredibly like exhausting both mentally and, I mean, I find it more physically exhausting than mentally, but I've been told by my lectures before that I am just a little bit strange in that nothing really grosses me out. really like even when I was on placement there was some cases where the experience technicians were like that's gross and I was like it doesn't really yeah bother me um but definitely like the
脑子里一下子也想不出来。我想这可能需要更多的时间去体会。那你觉得这份工作是你余生都会一直做下去的吗？我们之前也聊过这个。对。我们再深入探讨一下吧。这份工作在精神上都极其消耗体力——我的意思是，我觉得它在体力上的消耗比精神上更大，不过我的讲师以前曾对我说过，我这个人其实有点奇怪，因为没有什么东西能真正把我恶心到。真的，甚至当我还在实习时，一些经验丰富的技术员都觉得“这太恶心了”，而我却觉得这其实并不会困扰我。不过毫无疑问，体力的消耗
physical exhaustion and because that you know it makes me have this more appreciation for life it's like do I want to be spending my life working all the time because it's very because it's long hours because you know people are dying all the time and there's never any there's never any stopped that. There's always going to be people dying. And so if you, you know, we have the weekend off and then you come back on Monday and it's just massive. Yeah. You know, and I think that's, I don't know if I could see myself doing it for the rest of my life. Like, I love it. I really, really enjoy it. But then again, and it's very much like a job where it's like, that's the job. There's not really much more to, you can't really progress up in the fields unless you do like further study.
确实很大。而且因为它让我对生命有了更多感激之情，我就会思考：难道我想把一辈子都花在没日没夜的工作上吗？因为它的工时很长，而且你知道的，人们随时都在死亡，这种工作是永远不会停歇的。总会有人不断死去。所以如果你——你知道的，我们周末休息，然后周一回来，工作量依然巨量。对。你知道的，我觉得，我不知道自己是否能想象余生都一直在做这份工作。我很爱它。我真的、真的很享受这份工作。但话又说回来，这也是那种“这就是全部工作”的职业，并没有太多进一步的发展空间，除非你去做更深入的学习，
so like once you start like that's that yeah you know like that's not like a typical job or it's like maybe not a typical job but like some jobs where you can progress yeah i think about a lot of our friends work corporate jobs yeah for the public service and there's very clear promotional pathways and like areas to excel yeah and have more responsibility but i guess when you have all the responsibility you need when you're like when you're starting yeah exactly like yeah it's like well why i start working i'll be 22 and then why I'm going to do that until I'm like 60. Yeah.
否则一旦你开始干了，现状基本上就是这样了。对，你知道的，这不像是一份典型的工作——也许说它不是典型工作不太准确，但有些工作你是可以获得晋升的。对，我想到了我们的很多朋友都在做企业办公室工作，或者是公共服务工作，那里有非常清晰的晋升途径和可以大显身手的领域，可以承担更多的责任。但我想，当你一开始就能承担你所需要的所有责任时——就是当你刚入行的时候。对，完全是这样。就像是：“好吧，我20岁开始工作，难道我要一直干到60岁吗？”
Like that's a long. So I don't, I don't know really if I'll do it for it. But like I do enjoy it and I definitely want to pursue it more. And I do like the medical field. I think, I don't think that I would. Oh, I don't want to say that I wouldn't do anything outside of the medical field because I do enjoy my animals. Never say never. My other little side thing.
这时间可真长。所以，我真的不知道自己以后会不会一直做下去。但我确实很享受它，而且我绝对想在这一领域做更深入的探索。我也确实挺喜欢医学领域的。我觉得，我倒不会说自己绝对不会涉足医学领域之外的工作，因为我也挺喜欢小动物的。永远别说绝不可能。这是我的另一个小副业。
Yeah, exactly. And I would never want to like fully be like, no, I won't do anything else. but I do definitely, I see myself working in it. And I think the placement definitely made me more confident in that because, like, my supervisor was so supportive and they really helped me just feel more confident in myself. Yeah. And that little self-doubt that I had that maybe I wasn't, like,
对，没错。我绝对不想把话说死，说什么“不，我绝不做别的事”。但我确实能看到自己未来会从事这方面的工作。而且我觉得这次实习绝对让我对此更有信心了，因为我的主管非常支持我，他们真的帮我建立起了更多的自信。对。我原本还有点自我怀疑，觉得我是不是没有
skilled enough to do this job or it just wasn't for me like that. They really helped reassure that. And so I definitely see myself, like, working there for at least some period of my life. Yeah. Yeah. That's good to hear. Yeah.
足够的技术来胜任这份工作，或者这根本不适合我。他们真的帮我消除了这种疑虑。所以我的确能看到自己至少在人生的一段时期内会从事这份工作。对。对。听到这些真好。对。
So one of the last couple of questions I really want to ask you is we've talked about how it can be rough, how it can be physically and mentally training, but there's obviously a lot of rewards. What kind of, what do you do to unwind? You know, obviously seeing dead bodies all the time and being exposed to death can be quite overwhelming. Like what kind of supports you in your personal life to be able to do that day in, day out when you begin working? I have a really kind of strong network of. Well, I have a small amount of very close people in my life. Yeah. Like my roommates and my mom and my partner, like, I can talk to them about that.
那么，我想问你的最后几个问题之一是：我们聊过这份工作有多艰难，在体能和心理上有多消耗，但它显然也带来了很多回报。你平时都是怎么放松自己的呢？你知道的，整天看到尸体并直面死亡可能会让人难以承受。当你开始正式工作后，在个人生活中有什么支持系统能让你日复一日地坚持下去呢？我有一个非常坚固的……好吧，我的生活里只有少数几个非常亲密的人。对，比如我的室友、我妈妈和我伴侣，我可以跟他们聊这些。
And if I, yeah, I tell them about what I've been through. And like, obviously I can't tell them a lot of specifics for legal reasons because of confidentiality and that. But it's good to be able to tell them at least if I've had a rough day. And those people are very important to my life. And if I tell them that I've had a bad day, they will be there for me. And I also have quite a strong, like, rewind kind of. I really enjoy me time.
如果我——是的，我会把我的经历告诉他们。当然，由于保密规定和其他法律原因，我不能透露太多具体细节。但至少在我觉得日子很难熬的时候，能跟他们倾诉一下感觉很好。这些人对我的生活非常重要。如果我告诉他们我今天过得很糟糕，他们会一直在那里支持我。而且我也有一个挺不错的自我调适机制。我非常享受独处的时间。
Yeah. I'm a very me time person at the end of the day. And I was telling you before, you know, I do my yoga. I have, like, a pretty strong, when I'm in a routine, I have a pretty strong, like, exercise kind of routine. Like, I keep myself, like, and the yoga for me is really nice. like I put on my meditation music and I just kind of step out of my head for a sec.
对，结束了一天的工作后，我很喜欢拥有自己的时间。我之前也跟你说过，我会练习瑜伽。当我的生活进入正轨时，我有一套相当规律的运动习惯。我会让自己保持状态。对我来说，练瑜伽感觉真的很好，我会放上冥想音乐，然后让自己的大脑暂时放空一会儿。
Yeah. And I think that's really important for me to unwind. Yeah, I think that's kind of the main thing. So like the, yeah, the connections that I have with my friends and family. Yeah. And so important. Yeah, exactly. Which I think is in anything is really important.
对。我觉得这对于我放松紧绷的神经非常重要。是的，我想这大概就是最主要的途径了。所以，就像我与朋友和家人之间建立的这种联系一样。对，极其重要。对，没错。我觉得无论做什么，这都是非常重要的。
But again, that community actually in the workplace and being able to talk to everyone. And actually whilst at uni, I've, it's been really like, drilled into us like, to make sure you're okay. We had a whole lecture series one time about your mental health and making sure you're okay. And we have to do these like reflections as assignments, which is essentially just... How do I feel? Yeah, our lecture is being like, are you okay? Because even when I wrote a reflection earlier this year, I talked about some of my
不过话说回来，工作场所中的那种同伴情谊，以及能够和大家畅所欲言，也同样重要。事实上在大学期间，这种理念就已经深深地刻在我们的骨子里了——学校会反复提醒我们要确保自己的心理状态健康。我们曾经有一整套关于心理健康的讲座系列，专门教我们如何确保自己状态良好。我们还必须把这种反思作为作业来完成，本质上就是……
personal experiences and how that was making me nervous to go on placement and continue in this career. But, and then my lecture actually reached out to me and was like, please come and talk to me about this. And then we arranged to have this one-on-one meeting. And we talked it out with her. And she was really lovely about it. So, like, it's been really good support from the uni.
我现在的感觉怎么样？对，我们的讲师会关心问：“你还好吗？”因为甚至在我今年早些时候写反思作业时，我还谈到了一些个人的经历，以及这些经历如何让我对即将到来的实习和未来的职业道路感到焦虑。结果我的讲师竟然主动联系我，对我说：“请来跟我聊聊这个吧。”然后我们安排了一对一的面谈。我和她一起把这些困惑倾诉并梳理了一遍。她对此真的非常温柔。所以，学校给予的支持真的非常到位。
But then again, in my personal life. But I think that's because I spend a lot of time, like, explaining to my family and friends, like, what exactly I'm doing kind of thing. So they understand it on a deeper level. Like, my partner knows everything about anatomy. Go off. He watches all my lectures like me and stuff. Yeah.
当然，还有我个人生活中的支持。但我想这是因为我花了大量时间向我的家人和朋友解释我到底在做什么，所以他们能够在更深层次上去理解它。比如我的伴侣对解剖学了如指掌。太棒了。他甚至像我一样会观看我所有的讲座。对。
Yeah, so yeah, that's really good. And I think final question, you know, the whole kind of theme of this is like, this is unconventional. Yes, right? You're doing something that is so important to society, I think is really overlooked. Yeah. Like when it gets down to it, like, I think that was half my surprise when you told me like, I'm, you know, I'm a mortician or like, I'm a, what is the job? Forensic mortuary technician. Forensic mortuary technician.
对，所以这真的很棒。我想最后一个问题是，你知道的，整个访谈的主题就是：这份工作非常非主流。对吧？你正在做一件对社会极其重要但我觉得往往被严重忽视的事情。对。仔细想想的话，我觉得这大概占了我当时感到震惊的一半原因——当你告诉我：“我是个殡葬师，”或者，“我是个……具体职位叫什么来着？”法医尸检技术员。法医尸检技术员。
And I guess if there's someone listening, maybe they found this episode because they're like, I actually want to do this. Yeah. Maybe they watch the same BBC series as you. Yeah. Oh, interesting. What would be like your one piece of advice? I definitely think to expose yourself.
我想，如果有人正在收听这期节目，也许他们是因为觉得自己也想做这份工作才偶然发现了这一期。对。也许他们跟你看了同一部BBC系列纪录片。对。哦，有意思。你对他们有什么建议吗？我绝对认为应该让自己多去接触和了解这方面的真实内容。
Because on YouTube, actually, because it's educational, there is numerous videos of autopsies. What? Yeah. That's how I started watching them in high school. Like I had a favorite autopsy in high school because you can, like, you can, like, you can, It's the same way that if you've ever seen like birthing videos are on YouTube. Yeah. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
因为在YouTube上，实际上由于它们具有教育意义，有很多关于尸检的视频。什么？真的。我就是在高中时开始看这些视频的。我在高中时甚至有自己最喜欢的尸检视频，因为你可以……就像你曾经看过YouTube上的生育过程视频一样。对，对，对。
Because it's educational. So it's not a band. It's not gory. Yeah. Well, I mean, it is gore. It is gore for the sake of gore. Exactly. It's like a medical procedure.
因为这些视频具有教育意义。所以它们不是那种毫无意义的血腥。这不是为了血腥而血腥。没错。这就像是一项医疗程序。
Yeah. So definitely expose yourself to those things because the times that I was feeling doubts was during lockdown when I couldn't have any of my classes online. And I wasn't going into my like anatomy labs where we had, you know, the catabric specimens and that kind of thing. And that was when I was like, God, do I really want to be doing this? and it wasn't until then I was more in person again and started actually being exposed to like the bodies that I like really like reignited my passion because I love like I'm very
对。所以一定要让自己多去接触这些内容，因为我曾经感到自我怀疑的时候，正是在封城期间，当时我无法上线下课程，也无法去解剖实验室——那里有防腐标本和诸如此类的东西。也就是在那时，我曾想过：“天哪，我真的想做这一行吗？”直到后来恢复了线下接触，开始真正直面那些遗体时，我才重新点燃了内心的热情，因为我真的很热爱……我对解剖学以及这一切背后的科学极其感兴趣。所以我会极力建议去接触这些，但同时也要确保这不会对你造成过重的心理负担，因为就像我刚才说的，这个专业的辍学率其实挺高的。不过话说回来，你永远不去尝试就永远不会知道。如果你真的对此感兴趣，那当然是件好事。不过话虽如此，我的这个学位目前好像要被我们学校取消了，因为他们觉得人数不够。
interested in the anatomy and like the science of it all. So I would definitely say that but also just making sure that like it's not going to be too much for you because that's like I said earlier that there's quite a high dropout right I think in this degree. Yeah. But you're like, again, you're never going to know until you try. And if you do have an interest, then that's good. But in saying that, I think that my degree is being canceled by my uni because they don't think there's enough.
那你打算怎么办？他们以后打算怎么开设这个专业呢？我想我的其中一位讲师希望能把它改成另一所大学的研究生项目之类的。总之肯定还会有途径的，但是，是的，这个领域非常小众。
How are you going to do? How are they going to do it then? I think one of my lectures wants to make it a master's program at a different uni or something. Like there will be a pathway, but it's, yeah, it's a very small field. It's definitely something that's hard to get into, I would say. It's not, well, first of all, it's not for everyone, but it's also, yeah, it's a very small, everyone knows everyone kind of thing. So, yeah. Think through your choices.
我想说，这绝对是个很难进入的行业。首先，它并不适合所有人；其次，是的，这是一个非常小的圈子，可以说是“抬头不见低头见”的那种。所以，请慎重考虑你的选择。
Yeah, and, yeah, and I think in the future it might be a bit harder. Like, I'm very privileged that I had the chance to do this degree because it's only been running since 2019, I think. Oh, my gosh. Yeah, very, it hasn't. Very amazing. Yeah. So, but I think, I believe they will do it. I know they do it in other states.
对，而且我觉得未来可能会变得更加艰难。我真的很幸运能有机会攻读这个学位，因为它好像是从2019年才开始开设的。哦，天哪。对，非常新。太棒了。所以，不过我相信他们会继续保留的。我知道其他州也有开设。
This is me talking New South Wales in general. Yeah. For the Australian audience. Yeah, for the Australian audience. This is not for an international. Because, well, the job is quite different in other countries anyway. Yeah. I can imagine.
我这里主要指的是新南威尔士州的情况。对，针对澳大利亚的听众。对，这是对澳大利亚听众而言的。国际听众可能情况不一样。因为，呃，这份工作在其他国家本来就相当不同。对，我完全可以想象。
Yeah. So it very much varies across the world. But yeah, I think that's kind of, yeah. If you really do have a passion for it, it's definitely worth it. Because it's an experience. Yeah. Because even the people I went on placement with, like I said, a lot of them might not even go and end up into this field. But they still went through the placement because what an experience.
对，所以在世界各地差异非常大。但总之，我觉得，如果你对它真的充满热情，那它绝对是值得的。因为这是一段独一无二的经历。对。因为即使是那些跟我一起去实习的人——就像我说的，他们当中很多人最后可能甚至不会从事这个行业。但他们依然完成了实习，因为这毕竟是一段绝佳的经历。
Yeah. You know, it's not something that everyone else is going to do. It's going to do. Yeah, like 99.999% of the world will never know what it feels like. Yeah, exactly. Well, thank you so much for coming on. No, thank you for having me. It's been fine.
对。你知道的，这不是随便什么人都能去体验的。对啊，世界上99.999%的人永远都不会知道那是一种什么样的感觉。对，完全如此。非常感谢你能来参加我们的节目。不，谢谢你们邀请我。这真的很开心。
Yeah. Did you enjoy it? Yeah. Yeah. Did we all learn something? Hopefully. Oh, my gosh. Hopefully.
对。你觉得过程还愉快吗？对。是的。我们大家都有所收获吗？希望如此。哦天哪，希望大家都有所收获。
Oh, I think we probably do. I definitely. learn something. This is such a fascinating episode and thank you for just sharing your learnings and your experience. Thank you. And to be honest, it makes me feel a lot better about dying that someone's going to wash my hair for me. Exactly. When I'm dead. We all, we do really care. Yeah. Yeah. It's honestly really sweet. Like I yeah. No, that sounds strange to say maybe I don't think it's strange, but like for other people listening being like, oh, what, this sounds sweet. But it makes me feel really nice that like there is this sense of respect for people after
哦，我想我们大概都有吧。我肯定是学到了东西的。这是一期如此迷人的节目，非常感谢你分享你的所学和经历。谢谢。老实说，这让我对死亡释怀了很多，一想到我死后居然会有人帮我洗头。没错。等我死后。我们确实……我们真的很在意。对，对。这老实说真的很贴心。我觉得……对，这听起来可能有点奇怪，或许在其他听众听来会觉得：“啊？什么？这听起来怎么会贴心？”但一想到人们在离去之后依然能受到这种程度的尊重，就让我觉得心里暖洋暖的。
they're gone. 100% yeah. And that there's people like you who are passionate about that and willing to do that work. Exactly. Any final comments before we wrap up this lovely episode? Oh my gosh. Not really. But just thank you for having me.
百分之百是的。而且有你这样充满热情并愿意做这份工作的人存在。没错。在我们在结束这期美妙的节目之前，还有什么最后的感言吗？天哪。其实也没什么了，就是非常感谢你们邀请我。
It's been really nice. Yeah. Yeah. I really hope that people have, you know, learned something or at least found it interesting. Yeah. I did. Yeah.
这段经历真的很美好。对。对。我真心希望大家能从中学到些什么，或者至少觉得这期节目很有趣。对，我确实学到了。
Well, thank you so much for listening. As always. Thank you to Laura. Thank you. And if you feel compelled and you really enjoyed this episode, share it wherever you feel. And leave a five-star review on either Spotify, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you're getting your podcasts. And remember to subscribe. Thank you so much.
好的，非常感谢大家的收听。一如既往地，感谢劳拉。谢谢。如果你心有所感并且真的很喜欢这期节目，请随心所享地把它分享出去。并在Spotify、Apple Podcasts或你收听播客的任何平台上留下五星好评。别忘了订阅我们。非常感谢。
On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84's big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s.
欢迎收听《Look Back at it》播客。对我和我来说，1979年是个意义重大的时刻。1984年对我同样重要。我是Sam J，我是Alex English。每期节目中，我们会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何熬过来的。我们将与朋友、同行喜剧演员以及最喜爱的作家一起畅谈，比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）畅聊80年代。
84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host, Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor?
84年真是疯狂的一年。确实是疯狂的一年。我觉得对于黑人群体来说，没有比这更重要的一年了。欢迎在IHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts或各大播客平台收听《Look Back at it》。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？欢迎收听由你们喜爱的治疗师兼主持人Kear Games带来的《Learn the Hard Way》。这个空间专门探讨黑人男性的心路历程，进行那些在其他地方根本无法安全展开的坦诚对话，而你正与一位深谙此道的持证专业人士一起交流。有多少男人背负着一副重型盔甲？
It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern.
它向世界释放出一种信号：你可不是好惹的。但仅仅因为你具备这种能力，并不意味着你非得这么做。欢迎在IHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts或各大播客平台收听《Learn the Hard Way》。2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德（Clayton Eckerd）被指控使人怀上双胞胎。但这场怀孕似乎是一场骗局。“欧文斯女士，你伪造了这份特定的测试结果两次，对吧？”“我伪造了一次测试。”这起事件动用了大批互联网侦探，才揭开了一个令人不安的规律。
Two more men who'd been through the same. same thing. Greg, a lesbian, Michael Maranini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped.
还有另外两名遭遇过同样经历的男子。格雷格，一名女同性恋者，迈克尔·马拉尼尼（Michael Maranini）。我的大脑简直要炸了。我是Stephanie Young，这里是《Love Trapped》。
Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了法律的制裁。欢迎在IHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts或各大播客平台收听《Love Trapped》播客。这是一档由IHeart出品的播客。由真人倾情呈现。本集目前暂无评论。点击转写文本中的任意句子即可发表评论。